(electronic music)
- What's up guys, Michael
here to talk about people,
but make them small and bald.
That's right, babies.
And specifically, is it good to have them?
Because increasingly, people
are starting to think,
"Not so much."
Recently, public figures
like Prince Harry and Meghan Markle
or Alexandria Ocasio-Cortez
are starting to argue
that having fewer or even zero children
might be the most moral
and/or most responsible thing to do.
Of course, for folks who've always dreamed
of birthing a little tyke
or two or a baker's dozen,
contemplating the idea
of not bringing life
to an adorable monster like this
is understandably upsetting.
So, it's worth asking:
is having a kid, or even a lot of them,
a positive way to pass down
your superb head of hair
and green thumb?
Or is there something
irresponsible about bringing life
into this slowly sinking
Titanic of a planet?
Let's find out in this Wisecrack Edition:
Is Having Babies Ethical?
So, how has procreation
historically been regarded?
Well, Christian morality has long held
that having children, if
you can, is a good thing.
In the Bible, God tells a bunch of people,
like Adam and Eve, and also Noah
to be fruitful and multiply.
And obviously, some people
do still take this imperative
very seriously.
If you don't believe us,
go meet some Midwestern Catholics
or just rent "Cheaper
by the Dozen 1 and 2."
But it's also an imperative
that's been challenged by philosophers.
For instance, take Schopenhauer,
a crotchety pessimist who thought
that we may as well be living
in the worst of all possible worlds.
And he didn't even live
to see the season finale of "Hawkeye."
He believed reproduction
was little more than an
unwelcome side effect
of humankind's endlessly failed attempts
to satisfy our desires.
A moment of physical pleasure, then,
i.e. doing sex could result in offspring,
thus continuing the human race
and the misery of its existence
via kids that will grow up and
be just as miserable as you.
It's like your middle school
health teacher told you,
"Sex has consequences."
Meanwhile, in his book,
"The Birth of Tragedy,"
Nietzsche paraphrases the
Ancient Greek wisdom of Silenus,
which was given to a tragic king
by a man with the ears of a horse.
"It is best not to be born at all;
and next to that, it is
better to die than to live."
To be clear, we do not
endorse this message
and we hope that Silenus' friends
gave him a big hug after he wrote that.
Philosophers call this view,
that it is bad to be born
or to have children, antinatalism.
The most prominent contemporary
proponent of antinatalism
is the South African
philosopher David Benatar.
We talked about him in our
video on "Attack on Titan,"
if you wanna check that out too.
Benatar, like Schopenhauer,
thinks the world is really, really bad.
But interestingly,
he argues that it would
still be morally wrong
to bring new human life into existence
even if the world wasn't a
greenhouse filled with farts.
See, Benatar thinks that
there is an asymmetry
between pleasure and pain.
We all know it feels good
to experience pleasure
and bad to experience
pain, but Benatar argues,
it's only bad not to experience pleasure
if you are conscious that
you are being deprived
of said pleasure.
Like, if you didn't know
that this 24-karat gold ice cream existed,
you couldn't be sad
that you will likely
never have the pleasure
of indulging in it.
But now you know about it
and we can all be depressed together.
Conversely, it's good not to be in pain
even if we're not conscious
of that lack of pain at all.
We don't have to be thinking
about how (beep) it might feel
to sit on a cactus
to be enjoying the state
of non-cactus sitting.
But now you are, so you're welcome.
Thus, the asymmetry
between pain and pleasure.
bringing people into existence, then,
gives them the ability to
feel pleasure and pain.
And this, for Benatar, is morally bad
because no amounts of pleasure
could ever outweigh the
wrong we've done to someone
by giving them the ability to feel pain.
So, thanks mom.
As it happens, Benatar
argues our own world
is characterized more by
pain than it is by pleasure.
And if you don't believe us,
just ask Ben Affleck's face.
But even in a hypothetical world
where everyone only experienced pleasure,
it still wouldn't be right
to bring someone into
existence, says Benatar.
That's because he thinks such a life
would be about as good as a
state of total non-existence.
For this reason, Benatar
argues having kids
can never be anything
other than a selfish act.
At one point in his book,
"Better to Have Never Been:
The Harm of Coming into Existence,"
Benatar even compares having
children to taking hostages
as people can use their children
to leverage better treatment in society.
One of his examples is if
two women need a kidney,
but there is only one available
and one of those women is a
mother and the other is not,
who does society thinks
should get the kidney?
But people aren't all questioning
the morality of baby-making
because they've read David Benatar.
For the most part,
it's because they've
been watching the news.
With this crappery
greeting us every night,
it's no wonder one in four
child-free American adults
say they plan not to have children
because of climate change.
As we all hopefully know,
the climate disaster is being
caused by the pollution,
in particular, the carbon
emissions of human beings.
It therefore makes sense
that reducing the number of
humans would help the crisis,
especially the number of
humans in developed countries
who are responsible for
the bulk of emissions.
For more on how to fix the climate crisis,
check out our Wisecrack Labs
video on carbon capture.
Over the past 200 years,
the Earth's population has
gone from 1 billion people
to 8 billion, and it's only going up.
Perhaps it would be right
to see this sort of growth
as unsustainable.
Now, Exxon is obviously
way more responsible
for this large-scale pollution
than you and your Honda Civic.
Still, individual solutions for combating
or at least mitigating
climate change to some extent
have become more well-known.
We're all aware we could be
reducing our carbon emissions
by eating less meat, flying less often,
or investing in an electric car.
Though, not a Tesla.
Please, never a Tesla.
We know that we should be
buying zero-waste products
or conscientiously sorting our recycling,
but empirical studies have found that
of all of the climate-friendly changes,
by far, the most effective would be
don't make any new little
polluting machines.
In other words, have fewer kids.
If you get rid of your car, for instance,
you might save 2.4 tons of carbon a year,
but if you have one fewer
child, studies have argued,
you save on average 58.6 tons a year.
This is what Harry and
Meghan are supposedly doing
by limiting their family
to only two children,
which we have to applaud.
If the average child emits
58.6 tons of carbon a year,
just think of how much pollution
the average Prince emits.
Who knew that ending the monarchy
was such a climate-friendly move?
But having children might not be bad
just because they're bad for the planet.
Benatar goes so far as to argue
that having children is bad
for the sake of the children themselves.
This makes sense.
I mean, climate change?
Now, maybe you don't think
that existence right now
is necessarily a bad thing.
I mean, you can order sushi
while you go to the bathroom
and we're getting to J.Lo romcoms
in the first half of 2022.
But you might be able to agree
that existence in the
age of climate change
already is or might
eventually become not great.
Even in the best-case scenarios,
life over the course
of the next few decades
is likely to get really
difficult for much of the planet.
Who's to say that a child born today
wouldn't eventually really
vibe with George Bailey?
- I said, I wish I'd never been born.
- It's generally understood
that parents feel it's their duty
to ensure their children
have the best lives possible.
But who can honestly make
that guarantee today?
So, this is getting pretty depressing,
especially if you like babies
or your name is Anne Geddes.
- [Anne] This is what it's all about,
the sense of joy that comes with babies.
- So what hope is there?
Well, some philosophers
would argue, plenty.
For many, arguments like Benatar's
don't really hold up because human beings
just don't work like that.
Consider, for instance,
the views of Hannah Arendt.
For Arendt, every human action
always meant a new beginning.
People, for the most part,
don't just do the same stupid things
over and over again for no reason,
unless their name is Sterling Archer.
- Lana, introspection is
the enemy of happiness.
So, my advice is don't always work for me.
- Has it, though?
(Sterling laughs)
- I don't know, that's the beauty.
- Rather, they are constantly striving,
if often imperfectly,
to do something new and hopefully better.
And this theory of Arendt's
doesn't just apply to adults.
It's also about children.
Children, after all,
are never simply carbon
copies of their parents.
They might resemble them in certain ways,
sharing similar experiences,
backgrounds, and proclivities,
but they are not identical,
and therefore, they are able
to do things differently.
Arendt used the word natality
to signify this fact:
"The new beginning," as she
called it, "inherent in birth."
For Arendt, natality
was incredibly important
because it's what helps
save us from disaster.
And she was making this
optimistic argument
after the horrors of World War II.
After all, if everyone
really was identical
to their parents,
if there was no new
beginning inherent in birth,
then we would always be
doomed to do the same things:
too set in our ways to
ever stop doing the things
that we know are causing
everything to go wrong.
Luckily, that's not the case.
I mean, just look at the
suburban teens on TikTok
posting videos about
why Frantz Fanon rips.
Their lame-ass parents would never.
Because children have the
capacity to do things differently
and better than their
parents, Arendt argued,
the birth of new children is
not only a morally good thing,
it's our only coherent source of hope.
Sure, things are bad now,
but our children are not doomed
to emit as much carbon as we do.
They can choose to be different.
Life in the age of
climate change might suck,
but that doesn't mean our children
will be incapable of
rising to the challenge.
Nothing, of course, is inevitable.
Natality does not mean
that our children are
necessarily destined to succeed.
They might grow up to
host a YouTube channel.
Who put that there?
It's not funny.
It's what I do and I'm proud of my job.
I'm proud of this.
But from the perspective of
the human species, at least,
continuing to have children,
despite everything,
is the only course of action
that really makes sense.
In this view, reproduction isn't selfish,
it's hopeful.
So, what do you guys think?
Are children a source of hope
or is this just wishful thinking?
Is it okay to bring new
human life into existence
or would we be doing our children a favor
by never having them?
Let us know what you
think in the comments.
And if you're interested in
learning more about this topic,
check out "Infinitely Full
of Hope" by Tom Whyman,
who just so happened to
write this very video.
Thanks as always to our
patrons for all your support,
and be sure to check out our podcasts.
Hit that subscribe button
like you're popping
today's birth control pill
out of its pack,
and don't forget to ring that bell.
And as always, thanks for watching. Later.
(upbeat electronic music)
I know about birth control
pills 'cause I'm a man.